el festival biarritz américa latina'
levantó el telón el lunes por la noche
en este pequeño balneario del país
vasco-francés con la proyección de la
película chilena línea de lima de maría
paz gonzález la historia de un
inmigrante peruana en chile
protagonizada por la famosa actriz
magaly solier en total 9 cintas compiten
por el premio el abrazo al mejor
largometraje en un certamen que se
extenderá hasta el sábado con otras dos
competencias en las categorías
cortometrajes y documentales el festival
de biarritz de este año se desarrolla en
un contexto particular en virtud de la
crisis sanitaria que afecta a francia
sin embargo muchas salas se mantienen
abiertas al público aunque con un aforo
reducido y bajo estrictas medidas
sanitarias en este año de elecciones
estadounidenses el festival decidió
hacer una selección de películas en
torno al exilio de los latinos en eeuu y
asimismo un homenaje al escritor chileno
luis sepúlveda quien falleció en abril
pasado en españa' por causa de ccoo vida